hey everyone welcome to nostalgia trip
the show where we talk about our
favorite games from the past and see if
they still hold up my name is Sam and
joining me today is John Luke and we're
going to be talking about the original
tomb raider
[Music]
back in 1996 3d games were still in
their infancy and games were
experimenting with what was possible in
3d spaces one pioneer was Tomb Raider an
action-adventure game that focused on
exploring ancient tombs solving puzzles
in shooting the occasional wild animal
Tomb Raider brought many revolutions to
gaming one of which was its protagonist
Lara Croft who has become one of
gaming's most iconic female characters
the series has been going strong for 22
years and with the release of the latest
game shadow of the Tomb Raider we think
it's time to go back to see how the
original still holds up today so this
week shadow of the tomb Raider's out
mm-hmm so it's only natural that we go
all the way back to where it began a
whole 22 years ago Oh 96 yeah
yeah it was a long time ago I came out
on the ps1 mm-hmm PC and Sega Saturn I
think it was the Saturn yeah I remember
playing the game when I was a kid yeah I
played to first but I did eventually go
back and play one and yeah a lot of a
lot of fond memories of these games I've
always loved tomb Raider's the series
I've played almost every Tomb Raider
game throughout the years and boy it was
just an experience to go back to the
original one because in some ways I
think it holds up and in other ways it
definitely does not hold up yes we'll
get into and there's a lot of things
that happened in the very first game
that they actually kept true to the
series all the way up until now which i
think is really interesting because from
first look you're like how does this
even relate to the new reboot but there
are a lot of things in the core game
design that they are in thematically
they kept intact yeah yeah like they're
just the emphasis on exploration and
like platforming I want to talk about
platforming because that so if you play
a modern game and then go back to Tomb
Raider you're gonna be very frustrated
with the way it controls and it's I
think part of it is certain clunky
control aspects that come with like it
was an early 3d game and we're certain
improvements they could have made to the
way Laura moves and stuff like that but
then there's also just like intentional
design to design decisions that they
made that the newer ones trying like
automate it a little bit where it's like
okay when you jump you sort of
automatically grab a Ledge or you
automatically you know like stick a
certain landing like they kind of make
it intentionally like floaty a little
bit in the modern game so like Laura
will kind of like stick to certain like
ledges and stuff like that and this game
they don't have any of that so it's all
that time visual thing time jumping you
got to make sure you're holding the
button so that you specifically grab the
ledge yep this game is incredibly
precise and demanding and it's it's
difficult positioning yourself I found
when I went back even just like every
like rotate yeah rotating and moving in
the game is so precise it's almost it's
that part of it doesn't hold up it's
it's really not fun moving around as
Laura in a three diamonds are definitely
I think works better when you're more
familiar with it the guy it's I don't
know if you for watching like speed runs
of this game but it's really fun
watching people who know like exactly
how to play it
oh it's amazing yeah I think that's
where a lot of the appeal of this game
comes from is sort of like discovering
and like mastering like the jumps and
like where to go and like how to solve
all the puzzles and then like replaying
it yeah it can be a little frustrating
though especially like coming back to it
at the time the game came out I think
that there was a lot of things that it
did differently mm-hmm that other games
didn't so there were so many ways to
move in a 3d space like different jumps
grabbing onto a ledge sidestepping like
all those things were they made the game
feel really exciting at the time yes
definitely there were so many ways to
move around and platformer a lot of like
platformers were very simple 3d
platformers were very simple and this
one felt complex and the levels and the
scale of the levels made it feel very
complex I think totally because there's
a lot of like you're jumping onto a
and then you have to jump onto a
platform that's behind you and above you
so you have to do like a high you know
backflip jump or whatever yeah like you
think of like like advanced like jumping
tactics in like a Mario game they're
trying to make it more realistic so you
have this like you know slower moving
character with realistic human
proportions for the most part polygons
okay yeah so it's like this interesting
interesting take where they're trying to
make a more like grounded platformer
yeah and I think they environments
you're saying how like big they are
they're actually they're big in that you
don't know where to go and and they're
very complex and and and sometimes a
little obtuse and where you're like oh I
had to go all the way over there to get
to this one spot right when I was a kid
I remember getting completely lost in
the very first level and I never beat
the game because I I was a child and I
was too complicated for me to figure out
right how to get out of the even the
first level I went back and I played it
later on you know when I was in like
middle school probably and and finally
figured it out but it did feel like
gigantic to me then right it's it's
relatively small in comparison to like
modern games especially like the later
Tomb Raider games yeah they have these
like massive giant open spaces now but
there is something about how they design
this where you're not sure where to go
that it totally works like the first
time playing through it feels massive
and it feels complex because you have
like no idea what you're doing I think
something that this game did really well
was the sound so yeah it's very silent
it is it's a very silent game but there
is music that musics great the music's
great I mean lately
serious music is iconic so you you know
that's amazing but also when you're
playing the game it goes between when
you're in the beginning of the tombs
it's very silent very quiet there will
only be like very ambient or like little
cryptic sounds that come in and out and
then when you're in those big encounters
with like the Velociraptor or I don't
know whatever other animal comes out I
ain't trying to kill you then there's
like this intense battle music that
great let's back up and then you know
you're in the beginning of another level
when it's dead silent again I think what
they did what the music was really cool
yeah the silence gave it an intensity I
agree I totally it like there's it
builds an atmosphere mm-hmm that just
like feels kind of like desolate but
like spooky yeah it was spooky game is
spooky and when there's like combat like
bears show up like it is still
frightening I that's the one thing that
I think is probably the most ridiculous
about this whole game is the animal
encounters I think they're so dumb okay
the very first I I think it's one of the
first animals that comes out of the bats
mm-hmm the bats are really dumb oh well
any time like you just a meet you walk
in a room and you just hear that sound
and you're like okay get my gun and
there's no aiming so you're just just
kind of pivoting and hitting the button
like all eventually guy guy might shoot
the bat now shoot up keep shooting the
bat I guess it feels like very
rudimentary AI where it's a lot of like
yeah it's just kind of constantly doing
that like jump like strafe and and and
the AI is stupid all the animals are
really dumb even the bosses are dumb
like you can literally just jump around
them in circles and shoot at them until
they die like it felt more like at the
time it felt really cool because they're
like she's got two pistols and she's
jumping in the air and shooting yeah you
know that side jump flip exactly but
like going back and playing it it's just
kind of a pain obviously like the combat
doesn't really hold up to me at all no
the combat is like terrible really bad
they've definitely it's gotten way
better and even like the weapon options
are like you have two pistols
you got the two shotgun things like the
bigger guns you have
is that a lot it was like like literally
for weapons to go in between or
something yeah if it feels like the
comments there just to kind of rake up
the pacing of like the platforming and
puzzle solving right
it's interesting how in like the later
games like the combat has become like a
greater part of like the Tomb Raider
games when I feel like it wasn't
actually that major of a deal and the
first one like I said it's kind of just
there to pace it out you know yeah so
the core of like the first Tomb Raider
game this was very much explore the
tombs find the keys open door pull
levers and open doors push your way
through these like complicated map
puzzles exactly and that was that was
like the bread and butter of the whole
series it's the whole thing really
there's a very like loose connecting
story that's sort of like an excuse to
go to all these exotic locations there's
not much to it especially like you know
I think they've done a lot better job in
the recent games the storytelling mm-hmm
it's really dumb the plot it's funny to
look back on the plot cuz it's really it
really is silly but the they still do
the similar things of the plot so it
starts out as like you're on a mission
to find a thing and then it grows into
this like very supernatural story of
like it's like Indiana Jones totally and
in and all I think old to murder games
have like continued that formula it's
just I think there's like more nuance in
the later games that you know this is an
early ps1 game it was very very
simplistic in its storytelling yeah but
it is it's interesting that like back
then I think the game obviously was like
really good so that helped but that the
zeitgeist was almost more around Laura
as a character yeah then it was like
than any other game I feel like before
that mm-hmm and she became like this
like crazy like gaming mascot oh yeah
she was everywhere
I mean she was just like the cover of
magazines like toys action figures you
name it
yes on it she doesn't have that
relevance anymore which is kind of like
I still think Laura's very iconic yeah
you know they just released like a new
tomb raider movie but yeah it didn't it
doesn't have that fervor that it was
back then
totally so when I was reading about the
history of the development of the first
game I was really interested to find out
that in the for Lara existed they had a
male character standing in and they
basically they were afraid that it was
too much like Indiana Jones because
essentially it's kind of what the game
is right so they were really going
through these concepts of character
creation and they made a whole ton of
different versions of characters that
you could play as in this story and
initially they were afraid that a male
audience young boys wouldn't want to
play as a female protagonist they
decided to go with Lara after like I
guess this number of reviews people seem
to like her a studio and like the
publisher liked her so they went they
rolled with it but it's funny to me that
she became so iconic it's like it's it's
that ultimate moment of like they were
wrong you know they were they were wrong
they didn't need to have a male
protagonist and she ended up being like
this incredible face at the time for
gaming and it was a lesson for everyone
and now it's so easy to get a female
piece in your game yay which I love it's
agree and that was one of the magic so
when I was a member growing up always
loving games my dad was really into he
thought it was really cool he got me all
these consoles and I remember being
affected by marketing at a young age I
remember when Xbox Live came out I
remember thinking it wasn't for me
because all the commercials were boys
playing games together and so I and I
distinctly remember that and it's
actually why I ended up getting a
Playstation first because the way that
they marketed the games weren't as
gender-based boys club yeah it wasn't as
gender-based in their marketing and the
games that were sort of their flagship
games were more appealing to me
despite Laura being a very sexy female
character I was I didn't notice that at
all when I was a kid and I was just
excited surely a badass girl in a game
right I was the most exciting to me
she's an adventurer she's kicking butt
like like literally killing animals and
people in this game it's very crazy at
the end of the day I think that is sort
of the lasting legacy of Laura and like
Tomb Raider as a series is you know like
they've you know she's changed a lot and
she's kind of developed more as a
character yeah she's very simplistic in
the first one there's not much to her
but it's like yeah like she's this sort
of represents this like iconic female
and gaming who like everyone can kind of
like enjoy and relate to on some aspects
mm-hmm so John Luke would you recommend
the game nowadays uh it's a yes and no
it's very dated in a lot of ways like
kind of the movement you know the early
like 3d design it feels clunky in spots
but there's there's something to the
platforming and sort of the lack of
automation and the fact that you really
have to like time your jumps that I
still think is kind of unique compared
to like most modern games and the way
they handle platforming so if you're
looking for like a really interesting
challenge I would actually say that
there is something to this game that is
still appealing and I would like to see
like really I would just like to see
like a Tomb Raider game that actually
like takes lessons from that and tries
to make the platforming more challenging
because I still I feel like modern Tomb
Raider games or maybe like a little too
automated on the platforming and not not
that interesting yeah it's really like
the puzzles in the combat that are kind
of the driving force at least for me so
I would love to see a new tomb raider
game like take inspiration from the
original I would recommend this game for
somebody who is looking for a challenge
mm-hmm the other perk is that you can
probably beat it in one day it's only
like everyone it's not a very long game
so it's totally doable in one day I
wouldn't recommend it to somebody who
doesn't like platformers it's basically
all this game is is platforming so if
you're not into platformers it's not the
game for you at all
or if you're used to very smooth
platformers yeah there's a there's a
real rough learning curve around the
controls that you're gonna have to get
used to and if that's if that's not for
you I think yeah yeah when I wouldn't
play it thank you for tuning into
nostalgia trip guys this show is gonna
go on a hiatus because it is the busiest
time of year for games got a lot of
content to make so make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and see what we
have coming up in the future
[Music]